kriegen der Ukraine und eine neue Ära in
den transatlantischen Beziehungen
seitdem wir Donald Trump im Weißen Haus
hatten für Europa waren die letzten
Jahre wirklich das lauteste Weckruf dass
man sich hatte vorstellen können
geopolitisch verschiebt sich gerade
alles und wir brauchen ein starkes
Europa und ein starkes Europa braucht
ein mutiges Deutschland vor einem Jahr
wurde die zeitenwände in Deutschland
ausgerufen und international haben auch
viele gehofft dass dieser Begriff sich
nicht nur auf Militärausgaben oder auf
Energiepolitik bezieht sondern eben auch
auf eine stärkere Führungsrolle
Deutschlands in der EU ähm das wird
einfach von Deutschland erwartet wir
sind die größte Volkswirtschaft wir
haben die größte Bevölkerung und wir
sind mitten in zentrale Europa trotzdem
tut sich Deutschland sehr schwer damit
natürlich aufgrund der Vergangenheit in
diesem Land viele tun sich schwer damit
stolz zu ihrem Land zu stehen und das zu
zeigen und Deutschland hat aber genug
Grund
sehr stolz zu sein wir haben viel über
den sozialen Marktwirtschaft gesprochen
Deutschland muss selbstbewusster
auftreten so dass Europa auch ernst
genommen wird in der heutigen Welt und
das heißt eine deutsche Führungsrolle
ohne deutschen Sonderweg und dann haben
wir eine Chance nicht von diesen
Entwicklungen überholt zu werden sondern
sie aktiv mitzugestalten Herr Röhl ein
Thema was ja Deutschland stark
beschäftigt aber auch Europa ist ja die
Migration ist Deutschland da
beispielsweise ein leuchtendes Vorbild
wo man sagen kann ja die können
selbstbewusst die Führungsrolle in
Europa übernehmen also beim Thema
Migration glaube ich weder Deutschland
noch die EU sollte da irgendeine
Führungsrolle übernehmen weil das ist
wirklich seit vielen Jahren eine
absolute Katastrophe was im Blick auf
Migration und Flüchtlings Politik
passiert egal von welcher aus welcher
Perspektive man darauf schaut ich
verbringen viel Zeit leben zum Teil
direkt an der EU Außengrenze auch als
Reporte sind ja auch oft bei den Themen
genau und da gibt's halt einen Grenzzaun
der der die EU von Afrika trennt bin in
sehr guter in der spanischen exklavec
Utah und da kann man eigentlich wenn man
da so einen Tag verbringt dann oder
vielleicht ein paar Tage dann weil dann
sieht man das ganze Versagen dieser
dieser Politik also wir haben einfach
gesagt so wir stellen jetzt hier in acht
Komma sechs Kilometer langen Zaun hin
und eigentlich ist das dann schon die
Lösung für dich gesamte EU oder für die
gesamte
Migrationsproblematik man versucht die
Leute auszusperren wenn sie dann hier
sind was man nicht so richtig was man
mit ihnen machen will gerade Deutschland
auch als das Land in das die meisten
Migranten und Flüchtlinge kommen hat er
überhaupt keine Lösung also gerade
aktuell wenn man mal weggeht von der
Führungsrolle in Europa schauen wir doch
einfach mal ganz aktuell was passiert
die Kommunen sagen sind komplett
überlastet nicht mal dafür nachdem die
flüchtlingskrise jetzt neun Jahre alt
also nicht mal dafür hat die Politik
eine Antwort also da wirklich diese wenn
ich dann höre Führungsrolle da bin ich
ehrlich gesagt raus weil wenn man diese
Probleme in dieser Problematik schon
nicht Herbert dann wie soll man den
ganzen den noch größeren fragen
vielleicht dann wirklich her werden
schön wäre es schon
mehr passieren da muss ganz eindeutig
viel mehr passieren weil wir sehen dass
diese Menschen zu uns kommen weil wir
eben eine tolle Zivilgesellschaft haben
einen sozialen Marktwirtschaft wir sind
wohlhabend und die Leute kommen hierher
weil sie hier sich ein besseres Leben
versprechen deshalb bin ich auch da aber
obwohl ich mich nicht dazu zählen würde
natürlich aber es gibt viele Leute die
nach Deutschland kommen weil es ein
tolles Land ist aber die werden dann zum
Teil komplett allein gelassen wenn sie
erstmal hier sind und das geht natürlich
gar nicht und und wenn sie von dieser
Außengrenze sprechen das ist äh das ist
unvorstellbar was da abgeht aber nur
aufzugeben und zu sagen okay wir haben
es nicht gepackt dann übernehmen wir
halt keine Führungsrolle das geht auch
nicht also man muss man muss das Thema
richtig anpacken und super schnell eine
Lösung dafür finden weil das was wir
jetzt machen funktioniert nicht was
heißt das für Sie ganz konkret
Führungsrolle einnehmen mutiger sein
selbstbewusster sein was soll
Deutschland ganz konkret tun also ich
finde Deutschland
in Deutschland sollte einfach mal die
Hand heben und ein paar gute Vorschläge
machen wir haben schlaue Menschen in
unserem Land ich weiß nicht warum wir
wir nicht in der Lage sind zu sagen okay
wir haben wir haben ein großes Energie
sicherheitspolitisches Thema gerade wir
starten einfach mal ein ein tolles
Projekt in Afrika zum Beispiel wir
überlassen ist nicht den chinesischen
Unternehmen sondern wir starten da ein
cooles Projekt schaffen Arbeitsplätze
dort und profitieren selber auch davon
also einfach ein bisschen neu denken
eine westliche alternativ alternativ
eine Antwort auf die neue Seidenstraße
Initiative da kommt so wenig von unserer
Seite und es braucht jemand der sagt ich
habe eine coole Idee lasst uns das mal
anpacken ich bin da völlig zu 100% bei
ihnen inhaltlich ich glaube das Problem
ist bloß dass diese Punkt echt
schmerzhaft wird weil wir müssen uns
eingestehen dass wir in den letzten
Jahrzehnten in Deutschland eine Politik
gemacht hat die sich eher ins Reich der
Träume immer verflüchtet hat
insbesondere der Rolle der aus und
Sicherheitspolitik die wir gespielt
haben wir wir müssen ja irgendwie das
Gefühl nach dem Fall des Eisernen
Vorhang jetzt wird die Welt nur noch
friedlich nur noch bunt und nur noch
schön und jetzt stehen wir hier da
erkennen plötzlich die gesamte Härte und
diskutieren in diesem Land über
feministische Außenpolitik das kann ich
auch machen ich kann auch über kreative
Ansätze reden und auch über über
Sichtbarkeiten aber wir müssen ich
glaube sozusagen echt wachgerüttelt
werden also mein Eindruck ist irgendwie
man hatten Gespür dafür man sieht die
Probleme man will bloß keine Antwort
geben man ist auch viel zu langsam also
wenn man sich überlegt dass das
Sondervermögen vor einem Jahr
angekündigt wurde und bisher nicht mal
ein Prozent davon
absoluter verteilt wurde und da ist auch
ein Krieg vor unserer Haustür dann fragt
man sich was braucht es noch so dass wir
aus dem Grund wer wünscht sich denn
eigentlich ein starkes Deutschland in
der Führung Hans wünscht es sich
Österreich dass Deutschland die starke
Führung übernimmt ich habe überhaupt
keine Probleme Mutter die Österreich
auch kein Problem mit deutsche Führung
wenn sie in der auf die Welt genießen
muss gleich nicht also dazwischen gibt
es noch etwas und ich glaube das ist nur
so einfach mit Deutschland allein ich
gehen wird was mir noch mehr sozusagen
fehlt ist diese starke Balance und die
starke Alliance mit Frankreich wenn die
zwei großen Staaten wirklich zueinander
stehen und miteinander was entwickeln
dann kann es was weitergehen die
deutschen fürchten sich immer ein
bisschen die Franzosen weniger daher
gemeinsam geht's vielleicht leichter und
ich meine Makro hat ein großes
europapolitisches Konzept vorgelegt ob
man das jetzt will oder nicht gut aber
es gibt eines wo ist denn das deutsche
Konzepte genau
über die Sicherheitspolitik die über
Krieg und über Waffenlieferungen
hinausgeht weil Sicherheitspolitik ist
nicht nur dass sie waffenlieferer eine
Rückfrage an Dich haben die Österreicher
erscheint mir gar nicht so als würden
die Europa wollen sondern eher als
hätten sie im Moment aktuell mehr Lust
auf Österreich jetzt auf Europa das
trifft er nicht nur Österreich also das
in sich gekehrte und das populistische
Element dass man keine Ausländer will
und eigentlich rundherum wie bereits
seine will das ist ja nicht nur ein
österreichisches Phänomen da ist es aber
leider besonders ausgeprägt weil wir
eine Regierung haben in Österreich die
besonders schwach ist also beide
gemeinsam haben ungefähr jetzt in dem in
den Meinungsumfragen so aus an die 30
Prozent ja 28 bis 30 Prozent und das
will man unbedingt mit populistischen
Forderungen die natürlich dann immer
gegen Migranten sind und so weiter und
so fort will man ein politisches
Geschäft machen ich hoffe dass das nicht
aufgeht aber es schaut so aus als würde
es aufgehen weil die die größte Partei
in der Zwischenzeit ist die FPÖ die noch
radikaler und noch mehr Rechte aber ohne
jetzt hier am Tisch populistisch werden
zu wollen muss ich da doch eine Frage an
Frau Speaker stellen sie mir auch eben
noch mal betont dass Deutschland dann
zahlen kann zahlen soll also Deutschland
ist
kann es denn nicht sein dass Deutschland
auch irgendwann selbst der kranke Mann
Europas ist und dann gar nicht mehr
zahlen kann und das glaube ich nicht
weil letztendlich profitieren wir ja
alle davon dass wir in einer Gemeinde
sind als Europa das was wir exportieren
geht zu über 50% an eure an unsere
europäischen Nachbarländer also wir
brauchen Europa genauso wie Europa uns
braucht und das ergänzt sich gut und ähm
das eine schließt das andere nicht aus
und wenn wir ähm wenn wir diese diese
Strömungen haben dass wir alle nur auf
unser eigenes Land gucken dann müssen
wir auch ganz schnell wach gerettet
werden denn als Deutschland als Polen
als Österreich können wir keine Rolle in
der neuen geopolitischen Situation
spielen aber als Europa dann doch aber
deswegen müssen wir halt auch wieder
eine Vision zeigen was wollen wir von
Europa wie stellen wir uns ein
gemeinsames Europa vor was was
entwickeln ich muss gestehen für mich
mal ganz schlimm war die Geschichte als
wir mal über europäische
Errungenschaften Sprachen und dann nur
die Abschaffung von Roaming Gebühren
mehr aufgeführt worden also wenn das
sozusagen der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner
ist dann läuft natürlich dieses
politische Projekt auch falsch und ich
glaube wir können das mit so viel mehr
Leben füllen als wir es bisschen tun
aber dafür braucht man ja können wir mit
einem großen Konzept Europa auch
verhindern dass noch mehr Unternehmen
abwandern dass wir noch mehr die
Industrialisierung erleben
naja also dass ich Industrie verändert
dass ich Wirtschaft verändert das ist
glaube ich so aber ja ich glaube schon
wenn wir zum Beispiel es schaffen dass
wir innerhalb der Europäischen Union
auch die gemeinsamen Rahmen noch mal
anpassen ne also wir sind natürlich da
auch sehr vielfältige aufgestellt aber
ich glaube ja und wenn wir das schaffen
dass wir ein attraktives
Zuwanderungsland sind für Fachkräfte für
für für für Spitzen Arbeitskräfte
weltweit dann hat Industrie natürlich
hier auch irgendwo einen Anreiz zu sagen
und natürlich optimalerweise noch eine
Besteuerung ohne übergewöhnsteuer aber
dann dürfen wir dann dürfen wir dann
dürfen sie natürlich nicht zulassen dass
in den USA ein instation Redaktion
abgeschlossen wird und wir saßen gar
nicht mehr dann Tisch und hinterher
Himbeeren und sagen aber was ist mit uns
und dann passiert nichts mehr dann haben
wir dann haben wir gesagt dass wir es
nicht gut finden und unsere Industrie
trägt trotzdem riesenschaden daran also
wir brauchen eine europäische Antwort
darauf und wir müssen bei diesen bei
diesen Überlegungen bei diesen
Entscheidungen die irgendwann in Zukunft
wieder getroffen werden
nicht zu unseren Gunsten müssen wir
dabei sein unsere Forderungen stellen
und ganz klar sagen das sind unsere
Interessen die wir hier mit vertreten
aber auch diese Signale werden ja
momentan nicht gehört ne also wenn ich
mir anschaue ist begann ja mit Trump sie
haben den Act gerade angesprochen dann
ist es ja auch ein Punkt wo ich
sozusagen vielleicht anfangen muss also
ich bin absoluter Transatlantiker nicht
falsch verstehen aber wo ich vielleicht
auch aus Europa anfangen muss meine
Beziehung zu den USA wieder in die neue
Ebene zu heben also gleichwertige ne
umso stärker die Europäische Union ist
im Austausch mit den Vereinigten Staaten
umso mehr kommt natürlich dann auch die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich wieder am
Tisch sitze wenn was entschieden werden
und nicht nur Randfigur bin aber dazu
braucht es auch ein selbstbewusstes
Europa das in sich tut und sagt wir wir
haben eine gemeinsame Politik gegenüber
China wir wissen was wir als Blog wollen
weil sonst sind wir immer der kleine
Partner und haben nie was mit zu reden
und das funktioniert langfristig nicht
vor allem weil wir eben eine neue Ära
haben in der transistischen
Partnerschaft wir brauchen vor allem
eine politische Führung die den Namen
Führung verdient
nicht gut ich liebe den Urlaub Schulz
durch meine gewissen Ausmaßen aber aber
da fehlt es mir natürlich schon er hat
natürlich jetzt alle möglichen Krisen zu
bekämpfen aber trotzdem man kann jetzt
schon ein bisschen mehr nach vorne gehen
oder ich glaube das muss sein und zwar
Deutschland muss ein bisschen nach vorne
gehen da bin ich vollkommen mit ihnen
mit Ideen mit etwas Erwartungen Leute
sagen die deutschen können schon aber
jetzt mal ganz platt gesagt bevor wir
nach außen gehen sollten wir nicht
vielleicht beispielsweise erstmal das
Thema Migration bei uns selbst lösen
also wenn wir das einzige Land sind ja
das z.B aufnimmt die die die ganzen
Flüchtlinge aus dem Erdbeben gebeten nur
aufgrund seines Nachweises dass
irgendwer mit irgendwem angeblich
verwandt ist ja das macht ja niemand
sonst in Europa dann ziehen wir
natürlich auch die ganze Migration an
uns da muss schon einen Umdenken
erfolgen und bitte kein Zufall dass die
AFD stärker ist in manchen Umfragen als
die Grünen ja das ist furchtbar aber das
muss man auch politisch berücksichtigen
und muss einen anderen Weg einschlagen
und warum sollen wir klein denken also
warum sollen wir sozusagen also ich
glaube wir haben jetzt in Deutschland
bewiesen dass wir die Lösung für eine
vernünftige Migrationspolitik in den
letzten Jahren auch nicht hinbekommen
haben also allein wenn ich mir die
Berliner Situation angucke katja Kipping
schreit irgendwie wir brauchen jetzt für
120.000 Menschen wieder Plätze und so ne
also ähm das ist schon schwierig aber
ich glaube ganz ehrlich wir müssen uns
europäisch beantworten die Problematik
ist wir müssen es halt dann auch
einfordern und ähm
Olaf Scholz hat ja letztens auch in dem
Aufsatz geschrieben dass er sozusagen
sich ein starkes Europa wünscht aber
ohne Blockbildung ich glaube wir sind
schon längst in der Blockbildung ohne
dass uns das irgendwo in gewisser Weise
bewusst ist und der Block heißt halt
heute nicht mehr irgendwie Westen gegen
Osten sondern der Block ist heute halt
eine liberale offene Gesellschaft gegen
autoritäre gesellschaftschaften und das
müssen wir anerkennen und da brauchen
wir antworten darauf wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt das ist also
eine Verzehnfachung jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie